si os hablo de 'alicia en el país de las
maravillas' todos sabréis quién es pero
si os hablo del caballero blanco pocos
sabéis de quién se trata el caballero
blanco es uno de los personajes de la
novela de alicia a través del espejo y
está retratado como una versión satírica
del típico caballero victoriano
se le propuso walt disney introducir
este personaje dentro de la película
animada de alicia grabaron una escena en
la que el personaje es rescatar y alicja
en el momento en el que se encontraba
perdida en el bosque a todo el equipo le
gustó mucho la escena pero finalmente
decidieron que no introduciría en este
personaje porque consideraron que era
mejor que alicia saliese del bosque por
sus propios medios
os cuento esta historia para
introducirnos a una versión del
feminismo distinta a la del discurso
dominante
cuando pensamos en feminismo se nos
viene a la cabeza la palabra igualdad el
feminismo es igualdad decimos pero
dentro del mismo feminismo hay
corrientes distintas corrientes que
aparte conciben la igualdad de modo
diferente y que siguen métodos distintos
para llegar a esa igualdad
dentro de estas corrientes se distinguen
dos principales el feminismo de la
libertad y el feminismo de género
el feminismo de la libertad defiende que
hombres y mujeres tengamos los mismos
derechos y las mismas obligaciones y el
feminismo de género considera que esto
no es suficiente que puesto que las
mujeres vivimos en un sistema patriarcal
no podemos decidir libremente porque
somos condicionadas por este sistema que
nos oprime
en palabras de cristina hopf summers que
es una conocida feminista de la libertad
el feminismo de la libertad combate la
discriminación sexual y otras formas de
injusticia con las mujeres el feminismo
de género sostiene que las mujeres
siguen estando esclavizadas por un
sistema omnipresente de dominación del
macho el sistema de género en el que los
niños se transforman en las
personalidades de género de macho y
hembra una destinada a mandar y la otra
obedecer este tipo de feminismo se ha
convertido en el credo de algunos
programas de estudios sobre la mujer
organizaciones feministas y portavoces
del movimiento de las mujeres
este feminismo de género es actualmente
el feminismo hegemónico es el feminismo
que todos conocemos el que redacta los
manifiestos y convoca las marchas
también es el feminismo del que nos
hablan en los medios y yo os quiero
demostrar como este feminismo trata a
las mujeres como si fuésemos menores de
edad
y os lo voy a demostrar en tres puntos
el primero la mujer no puede tomar sus
propias decisiones
simon de beauvoir es una referente de
este feminismo hegemónico si bien tenía
teorías muy interesantes también tenía
un afán totalitario más que evidente
se le planteó simón en la posibilidad de
que una mujer libre ya de incorporarse
al mundo laboral optarse por criar a sus
propios hijos a lo que respondió lo
siguiente
ninguna mujer debe ser autorizada a
quedarse en casa para criar a sus hijos
las mujeres no deberían tener esta
opción precisamente porque si hay tal
opción muchas mujeres la tomarán es una
forma de forzar a las mujeres en cierta
en cierta dirección mientras la familia
y el mito de la familia y el mito de la
maternidad y el instinto materno no sean
destruidos las mujeres seguirán siendo
oprimidas
no puede ser liberador algo que obliga a
las mujeres a despojarnos de un instinto
que por lo general solemos tener
no todas lo tenemos pero muchas mujeres
lo tienen
y digo obligar porque simón decía que
ninguna mujer debía ser autorizada
autorizada por simon en otras palabras
las mujeres deberían de liberarse de la
autoridad del hombre para someterse a la
autoridad de las feministas hegemónicas
porque ellas saben mejor que las mujeres
lo que es bueno para nosotras
un ejemplo similar lo tenemos
actualmente con los trabajadoras
sexuales las trabajadoras sexuales se
están manifestando por tener los mismos
derechos laborales que cualquier otro
trabajador las feministas hegemónicas
consideran que ninguna mujer escogería
un trabajo de este tipo por decisión
propia y si lo hacen es por necesidad
yo me pregunto cuántos de vosotros
trabajáis por gusto pero por lo general
la gente trabaja en parte por gusto y
sobre todo por necesidad cuando este
misma problemática se plantea con un
hombre el problema desaparece si un
hombre por ejemplo es actor porno es un
triunfador y ha conseguido vivir de
satisfacer su alta libido que es lo que
le gusta
pensar así es machista que la mujer que
diga que disfruta de un trabajo sexual
sea vista como una víctima y el hombre
como un triunfador es claramente
machista otro ejemplo similar lo tenemos
en españa con clara campoamor clara
campoamor luchó por que las mujeres
pudiesen votar en contra de la diputada
del partido socialista que que opinaba
que las mujeres si podían votar votar y
amar es decir no les votarían a ellos
clara al contrario pensaba que la única
forma de que una mujer sepa lo que es
bueno para ella una mujer y cualquier
persona es que pueda decidir por sí
misma y en sus propias palabras la
libertad se aprende haciéndolo
segundo punto las mujeres necesitamos
tratos especiales
las feministas hegemónicas apuestan por
la discriminación positiva las
feministas de la libertad opinamos que
esto es humillante nos han llegado a
comparar con minusválidos puesto que
dicen que partimos de una posición de
inferioridad y por ello necesitamos
tratos especiales para igualarnos a los
hombres
en españa' por ley las mujeres y los
hombres tenemos que cobrar exactamente
lo mismo por hacer exactamente el mismo
trabajo si una mujer considera que está
cobrando lo menos que un hombre solo por
ser mujer puede denunciar y la ley la
ampara
hay que tener en cuenta que las mujeres
e incorporamos al mundo laboral después
de los hombres y aún así habiéndolo
tenido muchísimo más difícil fuimos
capaces de llegar a los puestos de
trabajo que nosotros deseábamos habiendo
en la actualidad mujeres empresarias
mujeres incluso presidentas porque
necesitamos cuotas y ayudas ahora y no
antes porque necesitamos ayudas cuando
ya tenemos la mayoría del camino
recorrido
las mujeres no necesitamos ayudas ni
cuotas especiales
necesitamos ser capaces de llegar a los
puestos de trabajo que nosotros deseemos
por nuestros propios medios de forma que
podamos sentirnos satisfechas de
nuestros logros
marie curie fue una científica pionera
en el campo de la radioactividad ganó
dos premios nobel por física y química y
también fue la primera mujer en dar
clases en la universidad de parís ella
decía la vida no es fácil para ninguno
de nosotros pero que importa hay que
perseverar y sobre todo tener confianza
en uno mismo hay que sentirse dotado
para realizar alguna cosa y esa cosa hay
que alcanzarla cueste lo que cueste hay
que tener en cuenta que mari decía esto
cuando el techo de cristal era un enorme
muro de piedra
actualmente hay más mujeres graduándose
universidades sí que es cierto que hay
carreras donde la mayoría son hombres
pero también hay carreras donde la
mayoría son mujeres el problema siempre
surge con la decisión de la mujer se le
dice a la mujer que debería de optar por
una carrera donde la mayoría no sean
hombres pero nunca se le dice a un
hombre que tenga que optar por una
carrera donde la mayoría sean mujeres
algo similar sucede con los puestos de
trabajo se anima a la mujer a que opte
por puestos de trabajo mayoritariamente
masculinos como puede ser empresario
pero nunca se le anima a que opte por
otros trabajos mayoritariamente
masculina como puede ser minero o el
trabajo en la obra la igualdad
solamente se pide cuando conviene
por lo general los hombres tienen menor
aversión al riesgo y es por esto que
ocupan los puestos más altos pero
también los más bajos como decía él en
la cloning lo explicaba ya muy bien
hay muchos hombres más hombres genios
pero también más hombres necios
las mujeres por lo general solemos
mantenernos en un equilibrio esto puede
cambiar sí pero si esto cambia ser algo
que surja de la sociedad civil y no
impuesto desde las instituciones
tercer punto necesitamos leyes
especiales este es el más polémico de
todos
según la ley de violencia de género
cualquier acto violento que cometa un
hombre contra una mujer tendrá una
motivación el machismo esto es falso el
machismo es uno de los factores que
puede intervenir a la hora de que un
hombre agreda su mujer dentro de la
pareja íntima pero no es el único factor
ni siempre interviene se ha llevado a
decir que es violencia de género que un
hombre se defienda violentamente contra
una agresión de su mujer que ha
comenzado la pelea pensar que ninguna
mujer en ninguna circunstancia es capaz
de dañar a un hombre ni física ni
psicológicamente también es machismo y
es por esto que un hombre que sea
víctima de algún tipo de maltrato lo
tendrá mucho más difícil para denunciar
porque no lo tomarán en serio se reirán
de él o pueden pensar que es un
masculinidad está siendo cuestionada
esto también es un problema las mujeres
pueden hacer daño es más las mujeres
dentro de la pareja lesbiana también se
maltrata como el natural dentro de la
pareja de iu también y una mujer
lesbiana víctima de maltrato va a
recibir menos ayudas del estado por no
entrar en la categoría de género
no deberíamos diferenciar entre víctimas
por su género su sexo su color de piel
ni su orientación sexual
a las víctimas tenemos que protegerlas a
todas por igual estadísticamente es
cierto que el hombre es más capaz de
utilizar la fuerza letal la mujer es más
dada una agresión de tipo indirecta esto
no significa que la víctima hombre por
ser minoría tenga que ser relegada o
tenga que pasar a una categoría de
segunda
decía elizabeth cádiz no pedimos leyes
mejores que las que ustedes mismos han
hecho para ustedes no necesitamos
ninguna otra protección que la que
aseguran sus leyes actuales para ustedes
proteger a todas las víctimas no es
proteger a unas víctimas en concreto no
es desproteger las es sumar no es restar
en españa que es uno de los seguros los
países más seguros del mundo estamos
llegando al punto donde el discurso del
terror del feminismo hegemónico está
haciendo que se vuelva a segregar por
razón de género se están creando
espacios no mixtos donde el hombre es
visto como un potencial peligro
el discurso del feminismo de género no
quiero ser valiente quiero ser libre es
una contradicción en sí mismo
no se puede no hay seguridad que esté
totalmente no hay perdón no hay sociedad
que esté totalmente 60 de peligros
y buscar una seguridad total mediante
protección institucional nos despojaría
de toda autonomía volviéndonos
dependientes de un estado totalitario
las feministas hegemónicas luchando
contra el machismo exagerando lo hasta
estos puntos están proyectando sobre la
sociedad una imagen de la mujer típica
de las sociedades más machistas del
mundo como si fuésemos seres desvalidos
y totalmente débiles y incapaces y por
ello sostengo que el feminismo
hegemónico es cada vez más machista
relegando a la mujer a la categoría de
menor de edad para satisfacer diversos
intereses que poco tienen que ver con
atender a las necesidades reales de las
mujeres
y ahora vuelvo al principio de las
charlas cuando se hablaba de galicia del
caballero blanco
las feministas hegemónicas están
haciendo del estado un enorme caballero
blanco que nos ofrece protección y
seguridad pero esta protección y esta
seguridad no son gratis lo que nos pide
a cambio es expreso obediencia
sin embargo las feministas de la
libertad lo único que queremos es que
hombres y mujeres juguemos al mismo
juego con las mismas normas de modo que
como 'alicia podamos salir del bosque
encantado' por nuestros propios medios
y quería terminar esta charla con una
reflexión hace muy poco leí que los
hombres estaban sobrerrepresentados en
las carreras de ciencias y que había que
limitar las plazas para hombres
vosotros imaginar que un chico joven
quiere estudiar ciencia y le dicen que
no puede porque hay demasiados hombres
reflexionar sobre si este tipo de
políticas entran en vuestra idea de una
sociedad abierta libre y próspera muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]